hello hell are we just starting welcome
to our TV show marry or kill Pizza
alcohol John Krasinski Zelko I would
pizza me too I would marry John
Krasinski too cuz he's a sweetheart
hmm and I kill alcohol have you ever
pretended you weren't Kristen Wiig when
asked all the time instead of
recognizing me they always tell me I
look like Kristen Wiig or like I look
like someone that was like on SNL or
something and I understand like I was on
vacation with my family and a woman came
up to me the woman said oh can I fight
Ben Stiller
and I was I was like no I'm I'm not Ben
Stiller do you do any vocal exercises to
help prepare your voice before scenes
know what I generally do is just come in
do all of the screaming first so by the
end of a five or six hour session there
is nothing wait for real no oh do you
and your character in the movie have
anything in common
real skinny legs I'm just kidding um we
both drive are you a spy no have you
ever used your celebrity status to get
you into something yes all the time
that's all I do
but more importantly the look on
someone's face when they know that they
aren't as important as you are is
priceless I love it what's your craziest
tabloid rumor that you have ever read
about yourself oh my god they're all
crazy I went to a restaurant with my
friend's parents and it was very loud
for them so he asked to move according
to the papers I hated my scene so I
asked to be moved three times and I left
my bag at the table and when they
returned it to me I yelled at the
manager and told them it was their fault
they just make [ __ ] up stop up careful
what you say
any what you really consequence from
what you spread
[Music]
you
[Music]